en realidad es un tremendo impacto el
que he visto con khan academy el mayor
impacto que veo es para los chicos que
en serio necesitan un reto y también veo
la chispa en los chicos que han
batallado los que en una lección grupal
de matemáticas se sienten perdidos
retraídos y que tratan de esconderse
ahora pueden esconderse detrás de sus
computadoras por así decirlo y trabajar
a su propio ritmo muchos alumnos son muy
conscientes de su lugar en relación con
sus compañeros algunos no quieren
parecer muy listos otros quieren
aparentar que son más lentos los alumnos
que dudan en preguntar y solo quieren
estar ahí en medio pero solo hacen las
cosas a medias y te das cuenta que así
estás dejando a dos terceras partes de
la clase fuera tiene que haber una
manera mejor de hacerlo khan academy
ofrece una forma de evaluar que es
increíble está ahí disponible
inmediatamente te da una idea rápida
dónde están los alumnos dónde están
teniendo problemas donde están
batallando yo sé con quién tengo que
trabajar y en que los puedo ayudar donde
puedo apoyarlos y proponer soluciones
les encantan esos momentos donde ellos
pueden serlo
ahora y enseñarme algo que crean que yo
no sé mis alumnos eligen metas semanales
para sí mismos con base en su propia
bitácora así que ellos están viendo su
propia bitácora ellos pueden visualizar
su progreso de forma gráfica de manera
muy concreta por lo general en una clase
de matemáticas avanzadas ya sabes ya
terminamos este capítulo este libro pero
los muchachos realmente no ven todo lo
que han logrado y hay mucho que ver y
esto no vuelve concreto para ellos en
ese momento estaba entusiasmado por mis
alumnos porque vi que es una herramienta
para ellos y que al final de cuentas los
va a ayudar a hacerse responsables de su
propio aprendizaje para que ellos
decidan que necesitan trabajar a los
chicos les gusta porque les resulta muy
atractivo y yo lo disfruto porque mis
alumnos les gusta los chicos se van a
sus casas entusiasmados sobre
matemáticas y eso es lo que ven los
padres hablan de matemáticas platican lo
que hicieron en clase les muestran lo
que acaban de aprender a hacer en la
computadora los padres conocen a sus
hijos mejor que nadie ellos pueden
resolver algún problema que su hija
tenga con khan academy si se ponen a
trabajar con ella le pueden decir
oye te acuerdas cuando estuvimos en la
playa hicimos esto y por esto ocurrió
ellos en verdad pueden ayudar a
relacionar estos conceptos nuevos con un
conocimiento previo si participan con
ellos en casa después de 21 años de
enseñar matemáticas he aprendido que o
les gusta o no les gusta y ahora creo
que tengo 27 chicos en mi clase que en
algún momento del día dicen oye me
encantan las matemáticas